talk now to the former Liverpool and
England's Striker John Barnes great to
have you on the program and you've said
that you're 100 behind Gary lineko why
is that
well first of all there are two issues I
was listening to the gentleman before in
terms of impartiality I don't know when
the BBC have ever been impartial in fact
BBC's reporting on the Guitar World Cup
was anything but impartial so it seems
like they want to pick and choose when
they want to be impartial criticizing
others or criticizing other countries or
other political parties or other
religions seems to be okay but of course
if you then criticize what goes on in
this country then it seems that they
will then come up with this impartiality
rule the second thing which a lot of
people took um offense to is is the
perception that Gary was was equating
um Britain to Nazi Germany which he
wasn't what he said was the language
used regarding the refugees is similar
to the language used in 1930s Germany
which it was and of course you can see
how that ended up and Gary is not saying
I'm not saying that that's how it's
going to end up but of course the
language used in terms of creating this
perception of an unworthy Refugee very
much like the Jews were unworthy um to
be German and Germans were better than
Jews that was the language that was used
and that's what we're saying here we're
talking about the the refugees coming
over and the language used towards the
refugees coming over on boats in terms
of them being rapist in terms of them
being criminals is different to the
refugees from the Ukraine and that is
what we have to to address and that is
what I want Gary and everybody
supporting him to talk about us talking
about the worthiness of different groups
of people because that's how
discrimination starts be it men women
towards the men in terms of the
worthiness of a woman towards a man
blacks towards whites gays towards
straight people and a Syrian refugee
coming over on a boat at in relation to
a Ukrainian Refugee coming over we don't
hear a language from the Ukrainian
refugees situation talking about rapists
and murderers but we heard about the
Iraqis and the syrians and that's why I
would like Gary young people to talk
about the worthiness of everybody
including the Syrian refugees in
relation to the Ukrainian refugees
raise some really important points and
points that many people are going to
have strong views about right but I
guess what some would argue is that is
Gary lineker the right person to be
entering this debate he's paid license
fee money that he is presenter of the
BBC's Flagship program is it right that
this kind of political debate should be
entering the World of Sport
should Gary lineker would Gary Lincoln
be the right person to talk about the
lgbtq rights and human rights in Qatar
we can't have it both ways we accept
that so why can't he talk about it here
so this is the point I'm making about
impartiality and we're saying that stick
to sports but when we want to criticize
other countries or other religions we
then say yes let the sports people come
out and talk about that but don't
criticize what goes on in this country
we can't have it both ways
uh interesting are you talking there
about the double standards and what you
would see as you can't have it both ways
certainly
um we've seen a wave of sports
presenters commentators refusing uh to
appear on the BBC in support of Gary
lineker do you think that they're right
to do that
well of course if that's what they
believe and they believe in what Gary's
talking about I'm not supporting Gary
because I'm Gary's friend or I played
with him I'm supporting him because I
believe it's right to do but as I said
let's not make this and this should not
be about guerninika and the BBC pund is
supporting him this should be about the
refugees and them coming over and that's
the conversation that should be had now
this is a distraction too and I'm
suppose the government is quite happy
with this a distraction to the cost of
living crisis a distraction to you know
the working conditions for the nurses
and and and and Railway workers and
postal workers so this is probably quite
welcome because of course no one's now
talking about real issues you know
because this really is just a sideshow
and it's inconsequential and it's
meaningless but we've had three or four
days and it will continue to run and I
think it's quite a welcome distraction
to really to realize she's from the
government
how do you see it being resolved because
you have got the people who are
supporting Gary lineker refusing to if
you like cross the invisible picket line
you've got the director General the BBC
apologizing where does this go
well of course a compromise will be had
um they'll come back together the
profile of lots of people will be raised
the profile of the BBC will be raised
that they'll do the right thing and
it'll be the state of score will resume
very shortly with everybody being happy
do you think that the BBC guidelines
themselves need to be looked at perhaps
it's a bit of unclarity shall we say a
lack of clarity in the guideline lines
themselves
absolutely very ambiguous and of course
Gary is also freelance so as to whether
he is fully employed by the BBC so he's
able to say things and I suppose Gary
probably thought well if I'm in Qatar
talking about human rights abuses then
why can't I talk about what I believe to
be right here as well so I think there's
a lot of ambiguity to it and of course
I'm not a lawyer but you can pick
different things out of out of contracts
and say yes you're allowed to but you're
not allowed to and everybody has an
argument so you know
um
how can you become more clear uh without
saying you're completely impartial you
can't mention it at all evening in
private life even if you're a freelance
uh but as I said I'm just sad that this
has been going on for so long when we
have many more issues uh to talk about
have you had a call to present match the
day
no no no no no I'm uh I think they've
lost my number I'm I'm called by many
people for many years you know what if
you volunteer to do it now I bet they'll
be on the phone straight away would you
do it
well only because only because there's
nobody else no I wouldn't do it
presenting if I was able to present I
would think about it but I got my
presenting Days Are Over
um but I suppose that anybody who's
going to be doing it now is because
there's nobody else to do it who can do
it but I won't be one of them though
thank you very much uh good to talk to
you today John Barnes there